Present only nature.
He came to that conclusion.
It was many people have
come to that conclusion,
but I think the two who've
outlined it most spectacularly,
we're Nietzsche and Dostoevsky had
niche is an unbelievably influential
philosopher.
You know,
I don't think there was anyone
that was more influential
during the entire course of the
20th century accepting a very,
very tiny handful of other
people accepting the scientists.
We won't bother with their,
where their discussion,
you could put marks in that category,
you could put Freud in
that category partly,
but after that the list
starts to get a lot thinner,
you know?
So maybe there's 10 people up and
out level and Dostoyevsky of course,
I think,
I mean,
if,
if you ever,
if anybody ever prepares a list of the
top 10 greatest literary figures in the
world,
he would be in the top 10 list.
You know,
I think he's perhaps second to Shakespeare
and may be above Shakespeare in my
estimation.
So these aren't trivial
people were talking about
and they weren't dealing with
trivial issues.
Well.
So then the question might be,
what's at the bottom of the
idea of a transcendent value?
And I want to want it to approach that
staying out of the metaphysical domain
as much as possible because you can claim
anything you want from a metaphysical
perspective and that's a big problem.
And so people will say,
well,
why come up with a hypothesis of God?
For example,
God could be anything.
There's a satire,
uh,
the flying Spaghetti Monster,
right,
is classic satirical representation of
a day at that the atheist types used to
buttress their arguments and fair enough,
you know,
as a satirical idea,
it's pretty damn funny,
but there's things about this that
aren't the least bit of music.
And the thing that's not amusing as well.
What,
if anything,
is our culture predicated on,
okay,
so what happened?
Well,
Nietzsche and Dostoevsky put this forth,
this set of propositions and out of
Dostoyevsky's line of thinking to some
degree grew soldier,
netsuite,
and so as units and documented
the absolute horrors of
equity predicated Soviet
society,
you know,
and we don't teach,
we don't learn about that,
right?
This,
I don't understand is that what happened
in the 20th century on the radical left
end of the spectrum is
not well documented.
Students don't learn about it.
Why the hell is that?
We learned about World War II,
we learned about what happened
in the Holocaust and fair enough,
we absolutely should,
but nobody knows.
It's a mystery to everyone when,
when I talk about what happened in
the Soviet Union and that's absolutely
appalling and that's to say nothing
about what happened in China,
which was equally horrible.
Yeah,
the system didn't work.
It was predicated on the wrong values.
Unless you think that that
sort of thing means work,
you know,
cause you,
you have to define that as well.
But it collapsed under its own weight
after it killed tens of millions of
people.
That doesn't really instill Ritz.
Not like Russia has recovered.
It doesn't seem to me like that's
a very good definition of worked.
Now whatever we're doing in the West
seems to work for all of its flaws.
And the question is,
are we just deceiving ourselves?
Is it just arbitrary power,
politics and opinion,
or is there something at the bottom of it?
Yeah,
so when Soulja knits and
wrote the Gulag archipelago,
he believed that the Russians would have
to return to Orthodox Christianity to
find their pathway forward.
And that's of course has made him into
a reactionary in the eyes of many of his
critics.
But that is perhaps what
is happening in Russia.
Although it's very difficult to tell
because Putin also seems to be using his
affiliation with the Orthodox Christian
Church as as it means to consolidate
power.
So the situation in Russia is unclear,
but a religious revival,
if that's happening in Russia,
and perhaps it isn't,
but if it is happening,
is something that unfolds over
decades and even centuries.
So it's not an easy thing to evaluate
when it first starts to happen.
Okay.
But soldier knits and drew the same
conclusions that Dostoyevsky did.
Fundamentally.
I'm not,
not in exactly the same way,
but very,
very close.
He,
he believed as far as I could tell that
unless people were willing to adhere to
some sort of transcendent value,
that they had no protection against
pathological ideologies and no protection
against the murderous impulses
that came along with them.
And I found his work in unbelievably,
I found his right.
Incredible,
powerful,
incredible.
I don't know how you can read that book
and not draw that kind of conclusion.
I think people who criticize soldier
nets and have never read the damn book
because that book is like,
it's like going into the
ring with Mohammed Ali and
being pummeled to death for
half an hour.
You know,
you don't recover from it that easily.
So
then young branched off of nature.
Okay.
And so niche,
his idea was that people would
have to create their own values,
roughly speaking.
And I think that's where niches is.
We,
uh,
is his weakest because it isn't obvious
to me that people can create their own
values.
And I think he fell into,
I don't want to be a casual critic of
nature because that's always dangerous
given that he probably had an Iq of 260,
you know,
I mean,
he was way the hell out
there in the stratosphere.
And just when you think you've
understood what he was talking about,
you can be bloody well
sure that you didn't.
But it does seem to me,
and he was running out of time,
he died young,
you know,
when he was trying to solve
this problem in a rush,
I would say.
And he hypothesized that people would
have to become superman over men,
roughly speaking in order to
deal with the death of God.
And that idea sort of branched off into
Nazi propaganda because that's in some
sense with the Nazis were trying
to do with their promotion of the,
of the perfect area.
You know,
now it's a mist.
It's a misappropriation of
nature in my estimation.
And it was partly because his
sister who was a perverse creature,
um,
uh,
what would you say?
Doctored his work in such a way so that
it was more easily appropriated by the
Nazis.
But there is some danger
in what he said too.
Because you know the,
the question is,
well,
if you're going to
transform yourself into the,
into the giver of values,
what stops you from inflating yourself
into something like a demigod and just
pronouncing what the
values are going to be.
So that's a problem.
You know,
you're going to replace
tradition with yourself.
Well,
there's dangers in that because
there's nothing to keep you humble.
That's,
that's the most appropriate objection.
There's nothing to keep you humble.
And those things can spiral
out of control very rapidly.
And they did say in the case of Hitler,
I mean it's easy to blame what
happened in Germany on Hitler,
but that's a,
that's a big mistake because it was a
dialogue between Hitler and the German
people,
right?
Hitler didn't create himself.
It was cocreation.
He said things people listened
and told him back what to say.
And then he said them and they listened
and they told him back what to say.
And it looped until he was the
mouthpiece of their darkest desires.
Now that's a good,
that's a game he was willing to play.
But you can't think about that as it
isn't like Hitler created Nazi Germany,
Hitler and the Germans
cocreated Nazi Germany now.
And a leader gives our articulation
to the imagination of the population.
That's what a leader does.
And you know,
you could say that,
well,
Hitler may be Hitler filtered what
the Germans were telling him through a
particular lens because he had no shortage
of resentment and desire for revenge
in his own heart.
You know,
um,
it's not like his life was his
spectacular success be before he became a
political activist.
And he was brutalized very
badly in world war one.
And he didn't get to
pursue his primary dream,
which was to be an art student in Vienna.
And he had applied three times
and got rejected all three times.
And so he was bitter about that.
He was basically living on the
streets after World War One.
It wasn't the world's happiest person,
and I'm sure he carried a fair bit of
resentment in his heart when he was in the
trenches in world war war one at,
at in one experience that he had,
all of his friends were killed by a
mortar when he had wandered off to go do
something else.
So,
you know,
it's hard to even imagine what
something like that would do to you,
but I can tell you when you're the
only survivor out of 20 people,
that's also going to give you an
enhanced sense of your own specialists.
Because the alternative is just to
think about how God damn arbitrary the
universe really is.